so Devin Nunez ultimately left the house
in Tokyo in fact he left the House of
Representatives Eric swallow of
California went on the Intel committee
and now he's getting booted off the
Intel committee and he's very mad about
it he went on television yesterday to
claim he's being ejected from this
committee out of quote pure Vengeance
watch
Chris the only person who supports this
is my wife who's like great you're going
to be home to change more diapers I love
it
um but the truth is Chris it's purely
Vengeance and I just want to walk your
viewers through this because this
happened uh nearly 10 years ago the FBI
told me that someone who had been
helping our campaign in a district was
35 percent Asian Americans may be
working with the Chinese government I
did what I hope every one of my
colleagues would do which was to help
the FBI get this person out of the
country it's only now that a trump Intel
official had leaked my cooperation to
suggest that there was some wrongdoing
on my part
yeah it's just political Vengeance this
is Eric's well but that's not true and
actually we did some reporting on this
because
what actually happened is important so
the last Director of National
Intelligence went to Capitol Hill and
briefed the Intel committees about
foreign Espionage threats and at the
time he recommended to the so-called
gang of eight that Eric swallowed the
man you just saw be removed from the
house Intel committee the most sensitive
Committee in the House of
Representatives why because he'd been
compromised by China and that's not an
overstatement a Chinese spy helped get
Eric swallow elected to the Congress a
Chinese spy raised money for Eric
swalwell's campaign a Chinese spy
campaign for Eric swalwell a Chinese spy
placed staffers in Eric schwelvel's
office
but the main problem and the main
problem that the Intel Community had
with Eric swalwell is that he had sex
with a Chinese spot
now we've made fun of him over the years
for this but it's real and swallow has
never denied it because he can't deny it
and everyone who's looked into it knows
that it's true so we're not here to cast
aspersions on Eric swallow's personal
life but if you're having sex with a
Chinese spy sorry you can't be on the
house Intel committee it's that simple
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight